Kaley Cuoco is giving a glimpse of Life
as a new mom I think it's going to be
interesting for people to see me what
you know this new phase in life and just
being very open about it check out these
snaps the actress shared with her
newborn daughter Matilda there's also
this cute pic with the little one she is
a total Daddy's girl Tom palpre also
boasted this sweet family shot fur
babies included if she's gonna be
anything like she is now she doesn't
stop moving so that means that that is
my child for sure so I think she might
be a little bit of a go-getter
definitely like Tom and I but uh not
stop non-stop moving which is exactly
how I am Kaylee and Tom announced they
welcomed Matilda March 30th and called
her the new light of Our Lives the last
time what's your plan have you read
books I have no plan and I've read zero
books so that's the type of Mom I will
be after revealing she was pregnant in
October the parents to beat couldn't
help but share their excitement
I'm not like a prep I mean anyone that's
worked with me is like does she know her
like I'm just not that way it's gonna be
great I trust the process
um Tom has Googled enough for the both
of us guys it's gonna be fine it's gonna
be fine yeah and Kaylee's friends think
so too like her Big Bang Theory co-star
Jim Parsons she was a mother-like figure
to me for many years on Big Bang even
though I'm tremendously older than her
what's wrong is she upsetting you
because I can make her go away
no she's the only reason I've I've
stayed this long
she was just she's a comforting presence
and it was a pleasure to work with her
day in and day out she's a very warm
person I think that child's lucky to
have her for a mother as
flight attendant co-star Rosie Perez
I thought he was winking at you earlier
but now I see it's just a series of
small Strokes yeah it was nice to him
exactly one time
just excited to meet the little bundle
of joy oh my God the baby cute Matilda
congratulations again Kaylee I'm coming
to La I'll be at your house well seems
Kaylee's enjoying her new role at home
but ahead of giving birth she told ET
she has no plans of stopping her other
love acting she's gonna come to work
with me Tom and I both love what we do
and we we've really made a commitment to
each working at different times and
we'll kind of trade off so that's really
that is our goal and we're hoping I
think that's going to work for us but um
again who knows we're this was the first
for both of us so we'll see
[Music]